الصين تستعد لارسال طاقه شديد الى محطه
الفضاء قصه منافسه شديده مع الولايات
المتحده وكمان نشاهد في الصور بكين تجري
الاستعدادات النهائيه لارسال طاقه من جديد
مؤلف من ثلاثه اشخاص الى محطه الفضاء
الصينيه وكاله الفضاء الصينيه الماهوله
قالت ان محمد
سوف تقلع من مركز
الاقمار الصناعيه الواقعه على حافه صحراء
جوبي في تمام الساعه
11:08 دقائق
المهمه ستستمر سته اشهر وستكون الاخيره في
مرحله بناء محطه الفضاء الصينيه في وقت
سابق من الشهر الجاري رست الوحده الثالثه
والاخيره للمحطه وهي واحده من الخطوات
الاخيره في اطار جهود استمرت لاكثر من 10
سنوات للحفاظ على وجود طاقم دائم في
المدارس من قرر ان يتداخل رواد الفضاء
لفتره وجيزه على متن المحطه مع الطاقه
السابقه الذي وصل في يونيو لاقامه سته
اشهر حيث يوجد في المحطه غرفه تستوعب سته
رواد فضاء في وقت واحد والمهام السابقه
الى المحطه الفضائيه استغرقت نحو 13 ساعه
من الاقلاع الى الاتحاد التزامن مع هذا
الحدث اعلنت رئيسه همم قوه الفضاء بالجيش
الامريكي ان التقدم السريع في القدرات
العسكريه الصينيه يشكل خطرا اكبر على
التفوق الامريكي في الفضاء الخارجي وبكين
احرز التقدما كبيرا في تطوير تكنولوجيا
الفضاء العسكريه بما في ذلك مجالات مثل
الاتصالات عبر الاقمار الصناعيه والمركبات
الفضائيه التي يمكن اعاده استخدامها والتي
تسمح للدول بتوسيع نطاق برامجها الفضائيه
بسرعه وفق رئيسه قوه الفضاء بالجيش
الامريكي
[موسيقى]